Holà, señorita !
Si, bien. Venido en el museum simulation technology
J'suis fier.J'suis fier, quand je parle comme ça, comme un adulte.
C'est incroyable
Aujourd’hui on est sur Museum simulation technology.
C'est un jeu hyper cool qui joue sur les perspectives
J'sais pas si vous avez déjà vu les petites vidéos, il y a même eu beaucoup de Vines qui jouent justement sur les perspectives
et qui du coup nous font vraiment marrer. Comme celui-ci par exemple.
C'est un petit jeu indé alors graphiquement ça va être dégueulasse mais parcontre ça a l'aire de te retourner le cerveau.
Aujourd'hui on veut ce faire retourner le cerveau.
Moi, j'adore la San Pellegrino.
Ce gaz délicat, permet à mes dents d'être en pleine forme.
On dirait pas trop une musique de pub! Mon gars sans déconner...
Bon allez!
Bienvenue, au musée de la simulation technologique.
C'est incroyable.
Allez, on y va.
Clique gauche pour attraper un truc.
C'est génial !
J'adore l'effet que ça fait.
C'est immense hein, regardez.
Si je vais en bas c'est un truc immense!
Et pourtant je peux le porter dans ma main et on dirait qu'il est tout petit.
Regardez.
C'est trop bien fait mon gars.
C'est génial.
Bon, une fois que j'ai ça, je fais quoi?
je le re....je le......
Aaah.... plus je le met loin plus il va être grand?
C'EST GÉNIAL !
Oh, le brain fuck mon gars j'adore !
Aah c'est génial...
Donc plus je fais baisser la caméra, plus il va être proche de moi: plus il va être petit.
Plus je vais l'éloigner: plus il va être grand.
Donc si je prends la Tour Eiffel.
Il faut que j'aille vers le bas pour qu'elle devienne petite.
Et que j'aille vers le haut pour qu'elle devienne grande.
C'est incroyable.
C'est hyper bizarre.
Tout le jeu est basé sur ça. On va avoir à faire des petites enigmes,
pour pouvoir accéder au niveau d'après.
Et c'est parti !
Il va falloir ce faire des escaliers pour aller là haut je suppose. C'est ça ?
Ah, c'est mini four.
Qui va devenir un vrai four.
Putain mec... C'est génial.
C'est génialissime.
Je vais dire mille fois le mot c'est génial.
C'est des marches avec des fours.
Là on est bon.
Là c'est parti.
Ça me permet d'accéder à la porte!
Bon là je pense! Là c'est facile encore mais je pense ça va très vite ce compliquer.
La Joconde.
Sans les millions de touristes habituellement posé devant.
Je peux la faire devenir immense.
Bah voilà.
C'est une grande Joconde.
Ah, c'est pareil il faut que j'accède à là haut.
Bah écoute mec on va voler les tableaux.
On va ce faire avancer. On va avancer dans la vie.
C'est dur là.
Comment je suis sensé les faire tenir en équilibre?
Ah merde. Je pense qu'on a foiré. Il va falloir qu'on recommence.
Alors attends...
Comment les poser pour pouvoir accéder à l'étage du dessus...
Telle est la question.
La Joconde est en place.
On va prendre Van Gogh, on va le faire s'accoupler avec la Joconde.
Normalement on va pourvoir y aller mec.
Ah, putain!
à la perspective est entrain de me brain fuck.
Mon cerveau fume littéralement.
Regardez. La fumée sort de mes oreilles.
C'est dur.
C'est très dur.
J'arrive pas mon gars.
Mon cerveau n'arrive pas à comprendre ce qui ce passe.
C'est un truc de malade quand même.
J'suis sur qu'il y a un.... faut juste faire un pont mec c'est sur.
Et là.. Attends...
Regardez ce que j'ai fait!
Je n'ai même pas compris ce qui c'est passé.
Mais par-contre ce que je comprends c'est qu'on arrive à la porte de sortie.
J'sais pas comment ils ont géré le truc mais c'est c'est..
Ils ont mieux géré que nous en tout cas.
Ça c'est sur.
Activity time...
Pour les enfants. Comme cette vidéo c'est pour les enfants.
D'après BFM.
Okey c'est parti !
Donc là il va falloir empiler les choses.
Finalement comme tout à l'heure.
Rien de bien compliqué.
Attends on va mettre celui là par dessus, logiquement on va pouvoir ce faire un petit pont.
De manière aisée.
Voilà! ce qui est bien c'est que ça sert à rien ce que je fais.
Je les empile pas du tout.
On va faire cube, rectangle, cube, rectangle
à là tu vois par exemple j'ai pas assez joué sur la perspective pour le rendre grand.
Ce qui fait que je me retrouve un petit peu euuuh coincé.
Si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
On est pas loin!
Putain!
Ah mais tellement... on peut voir ce qui ce passe quoi.
EH OH IL Y A QUELQU'UN??
Bon allez. C'est le cube qui va  nous permettre de rejoindre la voie lactée.
C'est faux.
Allez! Putain!
mais nan mais nan mais c'est.... mais qu'est ce que c'est que jai foutu là!
Oh nan. Oh nan!!
Mais quelle erreur!
NANNNNNN!
Pardon.
Nan, mais les gars soyez cool!
La je pense qu'il faut prendre un cube et un deuxième.
Et avec deux cubes logiquement je vais pouvoir y arriver.
Voilà!
Ensuite ça.
Voilà.
Et maintenant je peux y aller?
Oh nan! Mais là! Mais mec!
Mais c'est scandaleux quoi!
C'est vraiment mon orteil qui bloque!
Mais nan... putain...
Ah beh c'est pas grave.
Et voilà!
le tour est joué.
C'est vrai que l'on a pas l'habitude de pouvoir prendre un truc qu'est loin.
Le truc est immense et loin de moi mais je peux quand même le prendre.
Et le faire devenir petit pour....enfin bref.
Vous voyez cette phrase montre bien à quel point mon cerveau n'en peut plus.
Alors attends. Du coup logiquement je vais devoir faire tomber tout ça en bas.
On va tout mettre le long des trucs.
Et comme ça ensuite on pourra s'en servir quand on le veut.
Il faut juste pas que ça tombe dans la pataugeoire.
Okey
Je commence à prendre goût à cette musique.
Elle me donne envie de swinguer.
C'est pas grave. C'est pas grave.
J'ai fais des calculs. Des calculs scientifique.
J'ai, j'ai mit Pi et tout dans mes calculs et vous allez voir.
Vous allez voir. C'est.. y'a pas de risques.
Enfaite on va juste utiliser celui là en premier et on est bon.
Voilà.
Donc là on peut monter et ensuite on va ce servir des deux autres.
Comme on a fait tout à l'heure. Pour pouvoir...
...atteindre la voie lactée.
Tu veux pas! Tu veux pas être plus gros!?!
Nan mais c'est un sketch?
Mais le truc est devenu minuscule!
T'ain il faut que je le refasse grossir un peu là.
Mais mec!
J'ai perdu le truc!
What the fuck mec!
Nan mais c'est un sketch quoi...
Ah, il est là. Attends.
Nan mec ça va pas du tout.
J'ai comprit comment faire. On va faire une sorte d'escalier latéral. J'suis architecte okay.
Merde!
Je viens de le perdre!
C'est pas grave il en faut que quatre souvenez-vous de... de mon calcul avec Pi
Je peux juste pas faire un pont tout court en faisant ça?
Je me fatigue.
Je suis fatigué de moi.
Bon voilà.
t'ain j'ai failli bouché la sortie en plus avec cette merde.
Eh bein voilà.
Putain mais c'est incr... J'adore ce jeu.
Il est génial.
Faut monter là haut!
Oh, merde!
Comment on fait ça?
Il y a un ventilateur genre.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas? Il faut que je le fasse devenir géant et ça va faire tomber le pilier?
C'est un truc comme ça c'est sur.
Faut faire tomber la sortie.
Oui!
Regardez!
Ça bouge! C'est génial mec!
C'est trop malin de pouvoir faire grossir un objet qui a une fonction.
Et su coup sa fonction est décuplée.
Putain j'adore.
Alors, si un objet est entouré de bleu faites un clique droit pour le faire bouger de sens.
C'est une fusée. Alors ça logiquement il faut mettre ça à la...
à la verticale.
Comme ça?
Nan c'est de la merde.
J'ai pas comprit le but exact de cette fusée si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Il faudrait peut-être que je la fasse....aah peut-être..attends!
Je peux attraper la lune.
D'accord.
Putain...
C'est malin mon gars.
Il y la sortie qui est sur la lune?
elle est là!
Mais naan!
Mais nan!
C'est géniaaaal.
C'est génial mon gars!
Oh je dis oui!
Allez! Level suivant. Putain il m’envoie du rêve ce jeu.
Il m'envoie du putain de rêve.
Alors encore un truc avec des tableaux. qu'est ce qu'on va devoir faire?
Il y a une fenêtre et la...
On peut bouger la fenêtre.
Bah on fait grossir la fenêtre et comme ça on peut passer entre les barreaux.
Et le problème est réglé.
J'adore.
Mais mec! il faut que vous fassiez ce jeu mais sur Unreal Engine ce serait encore plus ouf !
Oula c'est quoi ce bordel.
Oooh il y a un délire de portail.
J'en ai fait grossir une à mort et du coup ça a grossit l'objet qu'il y a derrière.
En quoi ça m'aide à trouver la sortie les amis ce qui ce passe là ?
J'ai fait des portails immenses.
je vois plus rien, j'suis obligé de les rendre tout petits je vois plus rien.
Où est la sortie dans l'histoire mec ?
J'ai compris !
En gros la strat est d'empiler les deux cubes à la hauteur du mur et de foutre un des portail en haut pour aller sur le rebord du mur.
Si ça ce trouve je me trompe mais totalement mon gars. On sait pas.
Ah, c'est un truc du genre.
Attends. Je vais y arriver.
Hop
Ah putain !
Je sens que je smell qu'on est pas loin.
Pourquoi là bas il y a un mur immense c'est quoi ce délire.
Pourquoi tout a grossi ?
Et moi j'suis devenu tout petit?
Là je comprend pas !
Pourquoi quand je passerais dans ce miroir géant en frôlant le mur et passant là. Pourquoi ça ferait de moi quelqu'un de tout petit?
Ah ! Parce que...
D'accord !
Oh le brainfuck de bâtard ! Ok d'accord !
Enfaite le jeu par rapport aux portails je dois toujours faire la même taille par rapport aux portails!
Là quand je passe cette porte il y a 10 cm entre moi et le haut de la porte et bah à dans le jeu c'est pareil.
Ce qui fait que quand je sors d'une porte immense je deviens immense et quand je sors d'une porte petite je deviens microscopique.
Attends...
Nan c'est faux ce que je dis.
Aaaah! Mon dieu aidez moi!
Voilà.
Là je suis revenu dans le monde normal.
La porte là bas et les cubes sont petits.
Okey.
Mais quand je retourne dans le monde virtuel que représente ce portail là.
Hop!
Je me retrouve à l'endroit qu'on vient de voir où il y avait les deux cubes et la porte.
Sauf que je suis microscopique.
Ça veut donc dire qu'enfaite quand je passe ici je deviens géant.
Peut-être le but c'est de devenir géant et de passer de l'autre coté du mur?
J'sais pas...t'ain je me crois dans "L'attaque des titans" mon gars!
C'est incroyable.
ah... et si je retourne là?
Eh bein voilà.
On est passé.
Olala c'est génial! Les mecs sont allés super loin!
Donc enfaite depuis le début on était juste microscopique.
Et on a réussi a devenir grand pour passer au delà du mur.
Donc c'est bel et bien l'attaque des titans mon gars.
Donc on était enfaite sur..
Un jeu d’échec avec le ventilo de t'aleur voilà.
Tout n'est que tromperie. RT pour le complot.   "Rot"
Et voilà c'est la fin de ce petit jeu euh excellent.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plus.
Putain ça a été hyper intéressant comme jeu et les mecs ils ont poussé le truc.
Ça date de même plus je crois même plus d'un an.
J'espère mon gars que les gars bosse encore dessus à l'heure actuel. pendant leurs heures perdue.
Qu'ils vont nous pondre un truc encore plus brainfuck. Je trouve qu'il y a encore un truc à creuser enfaite.
Ecoutez il est gratuit n’hésitez pas à y jouer vite fait pour bien vous rendre compte de ce que ça fait.
J'sais pas si on s'en rend bien compte en vidéo...
ON CE RETROUVE TRÈS VITE POUR PROCHAINE VIDÉO! PORTEZ VOUS BIEN!  TCHAO TOUT LE MONDE!
Au revoir!